Luke Potter the shadow our defense
minister thanks so much for being on the
program today it's great to have you
um now usually with these interviews I'd
start off with policy or the big news
stories of the day but it is the
anniversary of the formation of the NHS
so I kind of thought we'd kind of rip
the rule back up slightly because you've
had your own experience with the NHS
recently uh haven't you I think you went
to the GDP about a bump on your arm
that's why you first went there right it
was yeah my other half had uh got a bit
annoyed with me that I had a bump in my
arm and I didn't know what it was he
said you've got to go to your GP and get
it sorted out as it turned out when I
went to the GP the bump in the arm was
just skin doing what skin does exactly
but then there was something on my face
and they pointed at me and although in
great makeup in Sky News you can't quite
see it I had a bump on my uh on my face
here I thought it was a spot that turned
out to be skin cancer and after having a
biopsy to diagnose that it was
um I then went for an operation where
they cut it out effectively and I now
sport underneath this makeup a scar that
is the the surviving bit of the
operation and for me you know wearing
that scar with pride is something that
shows that I managed to beat cancer by
doing it but when you're in the public
eye especially when you're a partition
you know you're very aware that quite
often on TV people are well the camera
Zooms in on what's going on here and
having a scar across your face can make
you feel something made me feel straight
away very vulnerable and exposed and
Cancer's horrible and when you hear that
you've been diagnosed with cancer you
think the worst but having the operation
that I did with the NHS who were just
simply brilliant looking after me at
every stage I think is a good reminder
that you know you're not Invincible you
do need to look after yourself and
especially in the public domain you
should try and model the behavior so if
there are if there is a bump or lump
that you're not certain about please go
get it checked out when it's great
advice and have to say actually
Alexander our macapotas is amazing but I
would never have noticed to be honest
from you I know that's maybe not the
right thing to say but you genuinely
wouldn't notice at all looking well it's
actually you um when I was on your show
a while ago it was actually one of the
first interviews I did after the
operation yeah and uh I was really
concerned that people would uh tweet
about the what's going on with his face
is there a scar there and actually
um I think being able to be open and
honest about that I think is a really
important part of the healing process
but also there's people right around the
country for whom having operations on
parts of their body that are visible
means that they can't hide that away
they can't they can't not tell that
story and I think just being able to
talk about it I think is an important
part of you know my healing process but
also hopefully giving
um giving more courage for others to be
able to do the same
with them
cancer it's a word that is really
frightening what happened when you were
first told that you did have cancer
you think the worst I mean you do I mean
the sentence is after I've got cancer
was a little bit garbled in my mind
thinking back on it because you're
thinking okay if I've got it on my face
where else could it be you know I've
only had a biopsy on my cheek what
happens if it's inside me elsewhere
um what happens if this is the end what
will happen to my family and so you do
worry about that and I think that's a
that's a reaction that is very common
for lots of people to have
um I was worried about you know what
this means my job whether I'd have to
take time off because there's only one
Member of Parliament for the bit of
Plymouth that I represent and if I'm not
doing it there's no one to step in
there's no relief there's no one that
can sub you in or out so I was concerned
about just what the impacts would be but
having you know a nurse be able to talk
you through okay this is what it means
this is what we need you to do this is
how we want you to look after yourself
and unusually having spoken to the whips
in Parliament now the whips empowerment
often don't get the best reputation as
enforcing party discipline yeah but they
were very Frank and honest they said
well we've had members apartment with
cancer we know that you will work too
late we know that you'll try and come
back to work too early and when you do
feel tired because you will do
we want you to know that you can you
know take the time that you need and
actually I think that's important
because people in the public domain are
still people at the end of the day and
if I'm trying to model best behavior
working myself into the ground to show
that uh it's the right thing to do it's
the wrong thing to do and I think you
know we all need to take time to look
after ourselves because we can't look
after ourselves we're not actually able
to look after others well I hope you
take your other half out for a decent
meal to say thank you for making you go
to the doctors and to the GPS in that
circumstance as well
um I'm interested to know a bit about
how you found your experience with MHS
because we talk about the NHS an awful
lot in the abstracts um whether it is
waiting times or
um a e times ambulances et cetera Etc
funding budgets
what's your first hand experience fit
like
well I've always found the most
overriding experience I've had with the
HS whether I'm waiting or not is just
the staff it's the staff that greet you
at reception
uh you know dealing with a waiting room
full of ill and sick people and worried
people uh the doctors that did the
surgery on me and my surgery under local
anesthetic so they were having a chat
with me at the same time them talking
about what this operation meant and
keeping me calm and that's the type of
work that takes place day in day out in
our National Health Service and I think
when you look at the figures around the
people are waiting at 7.4 million people
on NHS waiting list the highest it's
ever been well that's a level of figure
that is really hard to understand that's
one in seven people that means nearly in
nearly every single family there's
somebody in the country who's waiting on
an NHS waiting list and actually I'm
sure our viewers if you think about it
there'll be someone that you can think
of right now waiting for an appointment
yeah absolutely and the worry that you
have when you're waiting about is the
issue that you're going in to see a
doctor or a nurse about going to get
worse in the meantime will it be treated
is it going to be caught early enough
that is you know that weighs on you and
it is that kind of stress which is
contributing to people not participating
in the workforce you know one of the
reasons that we're not having the growth
that we need is because there's so many
people who are on a waiting list who are
able to then to go back to work or get
the treatment they need to you know work
properly I'm interested today because
look we've spent an awful lot of time on
today talking about how great the NHS is
Right reflecting on it
is it that great and do we actually need
to start having I guess a more honest
conversation about
the failings of the NHS I think you can
do both I mean the NHS A system that
provides Healthcare free at the point of
need so you don't have to worry about
how much money is in your wallet is a
system that we should be really proud of
and when that was first introduced 75
years ago that fundamentally changed the
health outcomes for millions of people
not having to save up scrimp and save to
go to the doctors to work out who was
going to get the appointment in their
family that makes such an incredible
difference but the Health Service now is
broken but the principle behind it isn't
and I think making the clear distinction
about NHS should always be free at the
point of need I don't agree and neither
does my party with charging people to go
see a GP or charging someone to go to
accident an emergency I'm not sure how
that would work but should we use the
private sector a bit more do you think
even if it is free at the point of views
well I think using the private sector to
help deal with this incredible amount of
backlog that we have seems to me an
appropriate use of the private sector at
the moment I don't have Private health
care and the vast majority of the
constituents that I represent don't have
private healthcare they rely on the NHS
the key thing that people want is for
their health ailment to be dealt with
efficiently and properly and quickly and
if using the private sector to reduce
that huge backlog that we've got just as
labor did last time we're in power in 97
to 2010 using the product Center to
reduce those waiting lists We inherited
well at the end of those 13 years we had
the highest patient satisfaction in NHS
history and the lowest waiting lists now
13 years of conservative government
later we have the lowest satisfaction in
the NHS sadly and the highest waiting
lists so it doesn't have to be like this
but at the end of it when you're looking
at the waiting list I'm looking at the
figures for my constituency about how
many people are waiting for care well
each one of those is a person each one
of those is someone like me or my other
half or my mum who you know like any one
of us we just want the best for them at
the moment the NHS isn't delivering for
what for the people that really need it
because we have a broken Health Service
now that is not the fault of any NHS
consultant or doctor or nurse or cleaner
it's the fault of the people who've been
running the Health Service last 13 years
that's the government well I mean I'm
sure they would say that there are other
issues just but you know the other side
of the story you know whether it's the
covid or whether it's
um funding as well and interesting to
talk thank you so much for sharing your
experience with NHS as well I think it's
really important to say actually to
reflect on what people's experiences are
and I'm sure there'll be lots of people
who have scars and particularly who'll
be thinking it's been refreshing to hear
someone talk about TVs thank you thank
you and the other story I want to talk
to you today is just a Boyle at
Wimbledon right and lots of people will
have seen this story
um what is your take on this do you
think that actually they're getting
their message across that's just
interrupted a tennis match who cares or
do you think actually they might be
turning people off by doing this oh I'm
an environmentalist I've LED Labor's
environment team for a number of years I
believe that we're in the middle of a
deep climate crisis and we've got to
take urgent action I also believe
there's not a single extra person who's
been convinced of the need for Urgent
action because the disruption that just
stop oil are causing to people we need
to take people with us to make the case
for the Urgent action that's required
it's not just low-hanging fruit like
Loft insulation we need to put in place
there needs to be fundamental change in
our economy and that does require any
government to be able to take the public
with them I don't think the disruptive
protests that we're seeing from just
stop oil are doing that if anything I I
think it risks turning people against
the urgency of the actions that are
actually required so yes we should be
making the case that climate change is
causing significant problems and will
those problems will get worse but if the
way we're doing that is for convincing
the people we need to believe that to
believe the opposite then I think we are
harming our own future and I'm not
convinced these tactics are going to
work and labor want to spend 28 billion
pounds a year on the green economy
there'll be some people who look at that
and thinking you know given the
conversation we've just been having
about the NHS there'll be hospitals
crying out for investment there'll be
people who are desperate to move up that
waiting list is spending 28 billion
pounds a year on the green economy
really the right thing to do in the
excess status I think it is on Vector
reads that Australia chancellor has set
out that by halfway through the next
Parliament under a labor government we
hope to be spending around 28 billion
pounds a year well that's not just money
spent in the abstract that's money spent
on home insulation complete retrofits
Street by streets it's on turning
Britain into a clean energy superpower
really taking the Renewables to its
possibilities investing in nuclear and
making sure that we are moving our steel
industry I guess green still all jobs
they all sound really important things
but why some people might say why don't
you spend and and 25 billion pounds a
year on that and spend 3 billion on our
hospitals for example well labor set out
a plan already to spend more on our
National Health Service by abolishing
the non-dome tax status how much is that
though 2.6 billion is that right so it's
billions a year that's nothing in
comparison to 28 billion on the green
energy Revolution as you say no but
we're already spending a large amount on
the National Health Service and I think
it's what we're looking at where the
money goes matters that's doubling the
number of medical space of course
Medical School spaces uh 10 000 extra
nurses and midwives and that will make a
difference to the way the NHS works but
we can't ignore the fact that if we
don't invest in cleaner Greener
Technologies not only will we not be
able to avert the worst parts of the
climate catastrophe that's facing us
we'll also be missing out on the jobs in
the green economy in the future because
there will be a country that will be
leading on hydrogen there will be a
country in Europe they'll be leading on
clean energy but why can't that be
Britain and I think we need to be
backing ourselves here there are
investors all around the world that want
to invest in these new technologies that
want to invest in Britain I think we
should be bolder about standing up and
saying actually I want those jobs to
come to Britain I want those jobs in the
south west of England where I represent
looking at how we can decarbonize our
Energy System how we can create more
highly skilled decently paid jobs in
that process now that's what the 28
billion pounds a year means to me I know
it's an insult that the government keeps
throwing around but actually I think
they're downplaying Britain's future
every time they do that we should be
investing in clean green jobs for the
future this is investing in careers for
our children and our grandkids so they
can form in the future and live on a
planet that's not in Flames okay thank
you very much it's been great to have
you on the program today